COACH OF THE INDIANAPOLIS
COLTS BACK HERE ON THE
PROGRAM. ALWAYS, GREAT TO
HAVE FRANK REICH ON THE SHOW.
HOW ARE YOU COACH RICH? I'M
DOING WELL, HOW MUCH BETTER
FOR TALK?
YOU BETTER FOR TALKING TO
YOU, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE
NARRATIVE THAT WE HAVE? IN
NATIONAL FOOTBALL LEAGUE
MEDIA, THAT YOU, AND YOU
ALONE HAVE THE SECRET SAUCE
FOR CARSON, WENTZ, LET ME
JUST JUMP RIGHT IN HEAD.
FIRST ON THAT SUBJECT WITH
YOU. WHAT DO YOU DO? I
YOU JUMPING IN ON THAT. NO NO,
IT'S ALWAYS ANYBODY WHO I'VE
EVER WORKED WITH OF THE
STAFFS I'VE EVER WORKED ON
KNOW. IT'S ALWAYS A
NEVER FEEL LIKE HEY I WANT TO
DO MY PART BUT IT'S A
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH WITH
THE PLAYERS, THE COACHES
TOGETHER THE TEAM,
OH, THAT. THAT'S WHAT IT'S
THE WHOLE PROCESS AND IT'S
THE WHOLE GROUP. SO THAT'S
THE WAY WE'LL APPROACH IT
HERE. SO HOW ARE YOU
APPROACHING IT WITH, WITH
WENTZ? WHAT WAS YOUR FIRST
CONVERSATION WITH HIM? LIKES
IT WHEN YOU WERE ALLOWED TO
AND YOU WERE ALLOWED TO L
CONNECT AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE. YEAH, NO DOUBT AND
IT'S WHAT EXACTLY WHAT YOU
WOULD THINK IN WANTED TO BE
RICH, OR WHAT ANYBODY WOULD
WANT IT TO BE, WHAT CARSON
WOULD WANT IT TO BE YOU KNOW,
MOVE TEAMS YOU GO THROUGH
WHAT CARSON HAS GONE THROUGH
AND AN OPPORTUNITY LIKE THIS
PRESENTS ITSELF.
YOU USE IT FOR WHAT IT IS.
IT'S TIME TO HIT THE RESET
BUTTON, GO BACK TO THE BASICS.
THE FUNDAMENTALS, START, YOU
KNOW, STARTING AT THE VERY
TRY TO DISCIPLINE YOURSELF
TO DO THAT AS A PLAYER EVERY
YEAR. NO MATTER WHAT. BUT
IT'S HARD TO DO. ONCE YOU'RE,
YOU KNOW, YOU GET THINGS
WRONG, BUT YOU GO THROUGH
SOMETHING LIKE THIS, A NEW
TEAM, NEW BEGINNING. LET'S,
LET'S, LET'S USE THIS TO OUR
ADVANTAGE. CARSON. LET'S AND,
AND IF YOU KNOW, CARSON WAY I
KNOW HIM AND HE'S EMBRACING
THAT HE WANTS THAT AND HE'S
WORKING.
SO HARD AND, YOU KNOW,
LOOKING FORWARD TO IT AND OFF
TO A GOOD START. SO, YEAH, I
MEAN, OBVIOUSLY YOU HAVE THE
ABILITY TO HIT THE, THE
RESET BUTTON, BUT BASED ON
YOUR KNOWLEDGE OF HIM, AND
WHEN HE'S AT HIS BEST, I MEAN,
WHEN HE, WHEN HE DOVE FOR
THE END ZONE AND HAD THE, THE
THE END ZONE AND HAD THE THE
MISTAKE OF OF DIVING, FOR AN
END ZONE, WITH AARON DONALD
BARRELING IN ON HIM IN THE
LOS ANGELES COLISEUM. A
COUPLE YEARS AGO, THAT WAS
THE MVP OF THE OF THE SEASON.
I MEAN HE WAS THE MVP UP
UNTIL THAT VERY MOMENT WHEN
HIS KNEE WAS BLOWN OUT AND WE
ALL KNOW,
WHEN NICK FOLES AFTER THAT,
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT AND HE WAS
AT THAT POINT, I THINK
EVERYONE PRETTY MUCH AGREES
YOU MAYBE COULD BE RE BUT
HE'S PROBABLY THAT DAY IF THE
VOTING'S AT DAY, HE'S THE MVP.
BUT SO I BELIEVE HE'S FULLY
CAPABLE OF THAT BUT YOU KNOW,
WE HEAR LIKE MOST TEAMS, YOU
YEAH WE WANT PLAYERS, WHO
CAN PRODUCE AT THAT LEVEL
BUT YOU KNOW, WE WANT TO DO
THE ORDINARY THINGS IN AN
EXTRAORDINARY WAY AND JUST
PLAY JUST
JUST DO YOUR JOB AT THE
POSITION THAT YOU PLAY BE THE
QUARTERBACK OF THIS TEAM, YOU
A LOT OF THAT MVP SEASON
WAS DUE TO THE FACT THAT HE
HAD A GREAT OFFENSIVE LINE IN
FRONT OF HIM IN 2017, THAT
WAS PLAYING AT A VERY HIGH
LEVEL. THERE WAS A GOOD
RUNNING GAME, THERE WAS A
GOOD DEFENSE, THERE WAS GOOD
SPECIAL TEAMS. THERE WAS GOOD
SPECIAL TEAMS, THERE WAS GOOD
COACHING. THERE WAS REALLY
GOOD PLAY CALLING BY DOUG
PETERSON. YOU KNOW, IT WAS
THAT. SO THAT'S THE APPROACH
HERE.
YOU KNOW, WE, I DO BELIEVE
THAT CARSON HAS WHAT IT TAKES
TO HAVE AN MVP TYPE SEASON,
BUT I ALSO BELIEVE THAT THAT
THIS POSITION IT STARTS UP
FRONT WITH THIS TEAM, YOU
KNOW, CHRIS BALLARD. AND I,
WHEN WE TALKED ABOUT IT WE
TALKED ABOUT BUILDING THIS
TEAM FROM THE INSIDE OUT,
FROM THE FRONT O-LINE, D-LINE
QUARTERBACK. SO, YOU KNOW,
AND THEN TERRY SLANDERED,
HE'S THE KIND OF THE
QUARTERBACK AT THE DEFENSE.
SO THAT'S KIND OF HOW WE'RE
GOING TO ROLL WELL IN IN JUST
ONE A FEW MORE ON THIS
SUBJECT MATTER. FRANK REICH
OR THE COLTS HERE ON THE RICH,
EISEN.
SHOW HOW MUCH THOUGH, YOU
COLLABORATIVE AND I KNOW YOUR
OWNER IS SOMEBODY WHO
DELEGATES. AND THEN LET'S
THOSE PEOPLE DO THEIR JOBS
AND BUT HOW MUCH DO WERE YOU
IN THIS CONVERSATION WITH
CHRIS POWELL? AND EVERYONE
AND I GOT THIS WHEN IT CAME
CALL FROM PHILADELPHIA OR
MAYBE VICE VERSA TO CHECK ON
THINGS THAT IT POSSIBLY GET
CARSON WENTZ HERE. WELL NO IT
WAS WHAT YOU JUST SAID RICH
IT WAS, YOU KNOW, MR. IRSAY
WAS CHRIS POWERED AND MYSELF
AND SO YOU KNOW NATURALLY AT
THIS POSITION WITH MY HISTORY
YOU KNOW, THEY THEY WERE
GRACIOUS ENOUGH KNOWLEDGE.
WAS COLLABORATIVE IN HIS T IT
DECISION BETWEEN THE THREE OF
US. YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY MR.
IRSAY HAS TO WRITE THE CHECKS
SO AND CHRIS HAS TO, YOU KNOW,
COORDINATE THE TRADE AND
FIGURE OUT HOW THAT'S GOING
TO AFFECT THE DYNAMICS OF OUR
PART TO GIVE MY EVALUATION OF
WHO CARSON IS OBVIOUSLY, YOU
KNOW MR. IRSAY AS YOU KNOW
BEING AROUND THIS, YOU KNOW,
ONCE HIS PERSPECTIVE AND
OBVIOUSLY CHRIS IS ONE OF THE
TOP OF VALUATORS IN THIS
LEAGUE. SO IT WAS A REALLY
DYNAMIC COLLABORATIVE EFFORT
AND AND THANKFULLY, WE WERE
ABLE TO GET DONE WORK. WORK
IT OUT WITH PHILLY WHERE IT
WAS A LONG ARDUOUS PROCESS,
YOU KNOW, NOBODY WANTED TO
GIVE AND YOU KNOW IT
EVENTUALLY I THINK FELT AWARE
WHAT IT WAS SUPPOSED TO FALL
TO WHICH WAS, I THINK A FAIR
DEAL FOR BOTH SIDES AND THEN
MATTER AGAIN, BECAUSE, YOU T
KNOW, CARSON WENTZ WELL, AND,
YOU KNOW, PHILADELPHIA WILL.
AND I KNOW THAT YOU'RE
HITTING THE RESET BUTTON
BUT I'M, I'M GOING TO ASK A
QUESTION THAT I'D LOVE TO
GIVE YOU THE FLOOR ON IS THE
SENSE THAT THE DRAFTING OF
JAIL AND HURTS. ABSOLUTELY,
SEND CARSON WENTZ INTO A BIT
OF A TAILSPIN THAT, YOU KNOW,
OBVIOUSLY THE OFFENSIVE LINE
AND OTHER THINGS WERE NOT
WORKING ON HIS BACK ON HIS
BEHALF. BUT HE ALLOWED THINGS
THAT HE CAN'T CONTROL TO
CONTROL HIM. I'M WONDERING
WHAT YOU SAY ABOUT THAT. NOW
IN INDIANAPOLIS. YEAH, WELL
DON'T HAVE. I DON'T THINK LY
HOW I FEEL ABOUT IT? THAT'S
MY OPINION. THAT I DON'T
THINK THE DRAFTING OF ANOTHER
PLAYER SENT CARSON. YOU KNOW,
IN A TAILSPIN. I THINK THERE
WAS I THINK IT'S COMPLICATED.
I THINK THERE'S IT WAS A LOT
OF DIFFERENT DYNAMICS, YOU
KNOW, EVERYBODY, YOU KNOW,
LEAGUE, EVERYBODY SHOULD HIS
SHARE, SHOULD SHARE IN THE
SUCCESS, AND EVERYBODY SHOULD
SUCCESS AND EVERYBODY SHOULD
SHARE, SHOULD SHARE IN THE
SHARE IN THE BLAME. IT
SUCCESS AND EVERYBODY SHOULD
USUALLY DOESN'T WORK THAT WAY.
SHARE IN THE BLAME. IT
YOU KNOW, THE QUARTERBACK
USUALLY DOESN'T WORK THAT WAY.
HEAD COACH, WHOEVER GM'S YOU
YOU KNOW, THE QUARTERBACK
KNOW TEND TO
HEAD COACH, WHOEVER GM'S YOU
BE THE FOCAL POINT. SO YOU
KNOW TEND TO
SHARE OF BEING THE FOCAL IS
BE THE FOCAL POINT. SO YOU
POINT OF THE BLAME AND THAT'S
SHARE OF BEING THE FOCAL IS
PART OF THE PROCESS OF BEING
POINT OF THE BLAME AND THAT'S
A QUARTERBACK IN THIS LEAGUE
PART OF THE PROCESS OF BEING
AND YOU GOT TO BE A BIG BOY
A QUARTERBACK IN THIS LEAGUE
AND BE ABLE TO TAKE IT BUT
AND YOU GOT TO BE A BIG BOY
YOU KNOW, NOW IS AN
AND BE ABLE TO TAKE IT BUT
OPPORTUNITY TO HIT THE RESET
YOU KNOW, NOW IS AN
BUTTON. IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY
OPPORTUNITY TO HIT THE RESET
FOR THE EAGLES TO SET THE
BUTTON. IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY
RESET BUTTON AND OBVIOUSLY
FOR THE EAGLES TO SET THE
RICH, YOU KNOW, I MEAN JUST
RESET BUTTON AND OBVIOUSLY
BECAUSE FROM OUR PAST GOT YOU
RICH, YOU KNOW, I MEAN JUST
KNOW NOTHING THAT I WANT MORE
BECAUSE FROM OUR PAST GOT YOU
THAN TO SEE THE EAGLES
KNOW NOTHING THAT I WANT MORE
SUCCEED. AND THIS BE A
THAN TO SEE THE EAGLES
SUCCEED AND JUST BE A WIN-WIN
SUCCEED. AND THIS BE A
AND HERTZ IS SUCCESSFUL. IT'S
SUCCEED AND JUST BE A WIN-WIN
ALL GOOD. I
AND HERTZ IS SUCCESSFUL. IT'S
GREAT QUARTERBACK PLAY. BUT
ALL GOOD. I
I'M GLAD WE GOT OUR, I'M GLAD
GREAT QUARTERBACK PLAY. BUT
WE GOT OUR GUY. FRANK REICH
I'M GLAD WE GOT OUR, I'M GLAD
INDIANAPOLIS COLTS HERE ON
WE GOT OUR GUY. FRANK REICH
THE RICH EISEN SHOW AS IF WE
INDIANAPOLIS COLTS HERE ON
NEEDED MORE EVIDENCE OF THE
THE RICH EISEN SHOW AS IF WE
INTELLIGENCE OF YOU AND
NEEDED MORE EVIDENCE OF THE
CHRIS BALLARD TOGETHER. YOU
INTELLIGENCE OF YOU AND
WENT AHEAD AND DRAFTED A
CHRIS BALLARD TOGETHER. YOU
MICHIGAN MAN IN YOUR FIRST
WENT AHEAD AND DRAFTED A
TIME, LIKE, SO CONGRATULATIONS
MICHIGAN MAN IN YOUR FIRST
THAT. I LOVE THIS KID. QUIT
TIME, LIKE, SO CONGRATULATIONS
IPE, I ASSUME YOU CLEARLY
THAT. I LOVE THIS KID. QUIT
GOT TO KNOW HIM VERY WELL AND
IPE, I ASSUME YOU CLEARLY
HIS STORY. WHAT? ATTRACTED YOU
FIRST-ROUND SELECTION 21ST
OVERALL ON HIM. YEAH. WELL,
YOU KNOW, YOU'RE GOING TO PUT
SELECTION ON THE GUY. YOU D
BETTER FEEL GREAT ABOUT THE
TAPE. YOU BETTER FEEL GREAT
ABOUT THE PERSON AND, YOU
KNOW, THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TO US. SO, YOU KNOW, IT CAME
TO CAME TO DAY ONE AND THE
DRAFT AND YOU KNOW, CHRIS I
REMEMBER CHRIS COMING IN AND,
KNOW THE WHOLE WAY UP TO THE
DRAFT FEEL LIKE THAT WAS OUR
GUY. BUT THEN, YOU KNOW,
WE DIDN'T THINK HE WAS GOING
TO GET TO US BUT
IT'S COMING IN THAT THEY SAID
I GOT A GOOD FEELING, YOU
KNOW, I GOT A GOOD FEELING. I
GOT A GOOD FEELING, WE'RE
GOING TO GET HIM AND SO HE
HE EMBODIES WHAT WE'RE ABOUT.
THIS IS A KIND OF GUY WHO
PUTS PUT ON TAPE ON AND OFF
THE FIELD IN THE LOCKER ROOM,
THE KIND OF PLAYER THAT WE
WANT THAT IS, YOU KNOW,
PRODUCTIVE, TOUGH, STRONG,
MENTAL TOUGHNESS, GREAT TEAM.
FIRST PLAYER WHO WE THINK IS
GOING TO CONTINUE TO ASCEND
AND GET EVEN BETTER.
AND THE REST OF YOUR DRAFT
BECAUSE IN YOU HIT THE
DEFENSIVE LINE AGAIN, SAFETY
ON THE BACKEND, FIFTH OVERALL.
SO, THREE OF THE FIRST FOUR,
ONE OF YOUR CHOICES WENT ON
THE DEFENSIVE SIDE OF THE
BALL. WALK ME THROUGH THE
THOUGHT PROCESS ON THAT
BECAUSE ANY AS YOU KNOW,
A LOT OF TALK IN YOUR TOWN
ABOUT NEEDING A LEFT TACKLE
AND THAT WAS NOT ADDRESSED IN
THE DRAFT THIS TIME AROUND.
WELL I'M GLAD I'M GLAD YOU
BROUGHT ALL THOSE UP AT FIRST
I SHOULD SAY BOY, WE EXCITED
ABOUT THAT. PIC, I KNOW
PEOPLE SAY WELL HE'S GOT AN
ACHILLES BUT I'M JUST TELLING
YOU YOU WATCH JUST WATCH THE
TAPE ON THIS GUY. I MEAN, AND
ISN'T, YOU KNOW, THIS ISN'T A
CAREER-ENDING TYPE OF INJURY,
YOU KNOW, YOU'RE YOUNG AND
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAL QUICK
AND COMPLETE, YOU KNOW, WE
WE GOT TO DINE AT WE THINK WE
GOT TO DINE AT. WE THINK WE
GOT TO DINE AT WE THINK WE
A GUY WHO COULD HAVE BEEN
EASILY BEEN A FIRST ROUND
DRAFT PICK OR SO EXCITED
WE GOT TWO GREAT PASS RUSHERS
WHO WHO ARE GOING TO GET
BETTER AND BETTER AND WHO FIT
WHAT WE DO? THEY PLAY LIKE WE
WANT TO PLAY, THEY HAVE THE
KIND OF FOOTBALL CHARACTER
THAT WE LOOK FOR IN PLAYERS,
DAVIS YOU KNOW AND THE TACKLE
THING RICHARD JUST IN. YEAH.
IT JUST IN PLAY OUT? I MEAN
THE TACKLES THAT WE HAD IN
IN MIND THAT WE'VE HOPED
FELL AT THE RIGHT SPOTS. IT
IT JUST NEVER HAPPENED. DID
WHERE WE WAS CHRIS TALKIN AND
WHEEL AND DEAL AND DOING IT
BUT IT JUST NEVER IT JUST IT
WE WERE SUPER EXCITED TO GET
THE TWO GUYS THAT WE
AND, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE A LOT,
WE HAVE OTHER WAYS THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE TO BUILD OUR
TEAM AND WE'LL CONTINUE TO
EVALUATE ALL OPTIONS. WE WERE
KNOW TIGHT AND WE THINK HE'S
DYNAMIC WITH THE BALL IN HIS
HANDS. WE THINK HE'S
EXPLOSIVE, YOU KNOW. SO WE
HE CAN ADD SOME PLAYMAKING
ELEMENT TO OUR OFFENSE SO
THAT'S A QUICK SUMMARY OF
THOSE GUYS AND I GUESS IN THE
LAST ONE FOR YOU KID THAT A
LOT OF COLLEGE FOOTBALL FANS
ARE FAMILIAR WITH IS THE
QUARTERBACK. HE TOOK IN THE
SIX MONTHS, A MAN, WHEN
YOU'RE, WHAT ARE YOU, WHAT
ARE YOU?
WHAT ATTRACTED YOU TO HIM AND
YOU KNOW WE ALL KNOW SIXTH
ROUND SELECTIONS AT
QUARTERBACK, CAN CAN WORK OUT.
WHAT CAN, WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT SUBJECT WITH
HIM AND THE FUTURE? YOU SEE
WITH HIM? WELL AGAIN YOU GO
BACK TO TWO THINGS, WE
ALWAYS GO BUT YOU KNOW, THE
TWO THINGS, EVERY TEAM GOES
TO THE LOCKER ROOM AND GO TO
THE TAPE AND GO TO THE
LOCKER ROOM AND WHAT KIND OF
WHAT KIND OF A PLAYER DO YOU
SEE? YOU SEE THE TAPE? YOU
SEE THIS GUY'S A WINNER YOU
KNOW NOTHING'S TOO BIG FOR
HIM. HE HAS WAYS AND MAKING
PLAYS HE'S PLAYED A LOT OF
IN FOOTBALL, HE HAS A UNIQUE
ABILITY TO EXTEND PLAYS IN
HIS OWN UNIQUE FACT. I'VE
BEEN AROUND GUYS LIKE THIS
BEFORE OR SEEN GUYS LIKE THIS
MANY TIMES THAT, YOU KNOW,
HE'S NOT A, HE'S NOT GOING TO
WALK. YOU KNOW YOU LOOK AT
HIS 40 TIME THAT'S NOT GOING
TO WOW. YOU BUT HE HAS. HE
HAS THIS UNIQUE VISION AND
BALANCE AND KNACK IN THE
POCKET THAT THAT WE'RE
EXCITED ABOUT AND THEN HE'S
SUPER SMART SUPER FOOTBALL,
SMART, GREAT TEAMMATE. SO WE
THINK IT'S A GOOD DYNAMIC IN
THE QUARTERBACK ROOM AND WE
THINK WE GOT A GOOD
QUARTERBACK ROOM, YOU KNOW,
EAST AND YOU KNOW,
WE DRAFTED EASTON LAST YEAR
CITED ABOUT HIM. AND SO WE'LL
JUST CONTINUE TO DEVELOP
THOSE GUYS COACH. THANKS FOR
THE TIME. I APPRECIATE IT.
LET'S LET'S CHAT DOWN ALONG
IN THE SUMMERTIME AND AND
RECONNECT AND I ALWAYS
APPRECIATE OUR CHATS. THANK
YOU, APPRECIATE YOU GOT A
RICH YOU GOT IT. THAT'S FRANK
REICH. HEAD COACH. THE
INDIANAPOLIS COLTS DOES NOT